cool about the GPTO OSS thing. Yeah,
throw that on. Uh, VB, you want to make
a host, too, just so I can mute people
and stuff?
>> Yes, you can always.
>> This is the worst feature of Zoom is if
you're in a meeting, you cannot change
the settings for that meeting. So, if
you want to add someone as a host, you
only notice it when you're already in
the meeting. And that's the only time
Zoom doesn't let you update the host
settings.
>> Indeed.
>> Um, I don't know if you saw this vibe,
Bob. The new OpenAI OSS model uses a uh
Rust runtime and then compiles Python
bindings.
>> That is correct. That is a correct way
to write code.
>> They they mogged your they mogged your
approach.
>> Um that is the only way to write code in
the future. Everything every piece of
useful software will become Rust slowly
and then users use Python.
>> Um anyone that isn't writing Rust code
for core systems is doing it wrong. But
for application layer code is definitely
never going to be Rust and it it should
not be.
>> Yeah, it reminds me of like when Golang
first came out and everyone using Golang
for all their REST APIs and like it
worked but like there was no OM and
there's no package management and you
were kind of like making a lot of
sacrifices and not getting a ton in
return.
>> Yeah, exactly. Like like we I think now
it's like we kind of feel like the
benefit of Rust to be honest like we
found huge huge benefits to using Rust.
Uh but mostly the real benefit is just
like you can make life really easy for
your users because you can build
bindings anything and that is like worth
a lot in my opinion for anyone that's
building for uh that's building for
builders.
>> Yeah, love it. Um cool. It's almost
10:05. Should we get into it?
>> Let's get into it. Uh hello everyone. Um
I'm Vivof. I make BAML and write some
code in Rust, I guess. And today I have
here with me Dexter who works on some
what do you want to say Dexter?
>> Uh Swix according to Swix I coined the
term context engineering back in April.
That's my claim to fame today.
>> Um and what we want to talk about here
in our weekly episodes is always about
how to build systems that actually work.
AI is pretty good for demos, but how do
you get it past a demo and make it
really really productive in any sort of
application? Today's episode is one that
I think deviates a little bit from what
we normally talk about which is how do
you actually write the code to how do
you use AI to write the code and how do
you build context engineering in a way
that's actually useful um because if you
not only have to start using AI tools
for how your user going to do them but
sometimes it's really valuable to know
how to be the user of these systems so
you can start building an intuition for
about what other people might be doing
behind the scenes
>> I think Dexter is one of the best coders
that I've seen
>> so like let's just learn from him and
see what he
Yeah. And and I think I think what's
really cool about this is like it's the
same thing that's true if you're
building like low-level LM pipeline code
that is like the exact prompt and
engineering every token that goes into
the context window to improve your
performance on that prompt is the same
concepts apply to using coding agents.
And I'm really excited to dig in on
that. And it's the same thing of like
yeah you could sit around and wait for
the models to get smarter. You could try
to like figure out how to get AI to get
AI to get AI to get AI to do a thing and
like somehow figure that out. But at the
end of the day, it's all about being
thoughtful and understanding a little
bit more uh deeply how these models work
and what makes them perform well and
what makes them mess up so that you can
get the most performance out of whatever
is available today.
Um so, uh quick show of hands in the
chat. Uh, drop a drop a C in the chat if
you're using claude code.
I don't know. I guess we could have done
Fs in the chat. I don't I don't know how
to speak. Gen Z.
>> Cloud code is amazing to be honest.
>> Oh, we got C CSI. I like that. Nice one.
>> A lot of cloud code actually. Um, it
sounds like people do like it.
>> Yeah. Um, so we've been working on cloud
code for probably I've been using it
basically since the day it came out. Um
we did a Twitter space with some folks
in the AI space and we were just like
vibe checking all of the it was like the
sonnet 37 version. Um it wasn't quite
that good. Um but when the SDK came out
and when CL when Opus 4 came out and
Sonnet 4 came out um we started to kind
of transform as a team um and there were
some engineers um at least one engineer
on our on our group that um was
essentially just like
shipping 2,000 lines of Go code every
day. And I got to the point where I was
like, I don't really know where this is
going. And also like I can't review
2,000 lines of Go code every day. Like I
I like not without more context. And um
it was all working and Ko found out
later like I was like I can't verify if
this is the correct implementation if it
solves the problem like let alone like
style and bugs and things like that. Um,
and so we went on this kind of like sort
of uncomfortable transformation as a
team over the last 8 weeks, which um,
kind of culminated in us developing a
workflow that was optimized for
not paying as much Vibbar's going to
hate this part, but not paying as much
attention to the code and paying a lot
more attention to what comes before the
code, which is the specifications and
the writeups and the requirements and
even the something like fairly low
level, which we call like implementation
plans. Um, and like I think the the main
benefit we got other than like hey look
we're all shipping a ton of really like
highquality features all the time using
claude. Um, like I think I shipped six
PRs last Thursday and I haven't opened a
nonmarkdown file in an editor in over a
month.
>> Um,
so very with very few exceptions writing
all our code.
>> Why don't we show people some of this
stuff? I think that's like the most
useful thing we can do. Like I think
we'll get it. Let's just
>> I want to open a little bit with the
why, but um so basically like there's a
there's a really dumb way to use I'm not
going to call it dumb because it works
pretty well for a lot of use cases. Um
but like everything you have when you're
working with these models, you have a
context window and when you use cloud
code, you can actually reverse engineer.
We put in the episode notes um
let's see,
share traces. Um, we put a trace of a
clawed call to Opus um that I captured
just using a proxy. I won't go deep into
that, but you can see the entire request
body here. 99% of it this is not my
prompt. It's the user message. It's the
system message. It's all the tools. Um,
this was for like a really simple like,
hey, tell write a threeline poem about a
cat or something. Some like test prompt.
Um, but a lot of what goes into the
context window for claude is like system
instructions.
Um, if you've used the cloud.md file,
your cloud.md,
um, there's cloud built-in tools,
there's whatever MCP tools you've
exposed. If you've connected a bunch of
MCP servers, these all go in. Um and
then there's whatever message that you
drop in user message which is like you
know make the website purple or whatever
it is. Um often like so the context
window for cloud code is 200k tokens.
And what we're going to do today is
we're going to walk through how to build
uh build your workflow in a way to take
advantage of this context window in a
way that lets basically lets cloud code
work really well in large code bases for
complex features with really advanced
like beyond just making a next.js site
to you know um sell sell uh burritos to
SAS delivery operators or something. Um,
so the dumb way is you send your message
and then Cloud works for a little bit
and it calls some tools. Um, I just
color these a little bit.
Does this make sense so far?
>> Yeah, that's good. I think it's good to
actually show people how it's being
built because the important part here is
like if if you're not thinking about how
these systems are working, you it's
really hard to actually engineer them
and like hack them to do what you want.
And I think the the inverse point is if
you're a builder building these kinds of
tools, if you make it really really
abstract for how your tools work, it
just you're just making life for your
users harder to get the right things out
of it.
>> Interesting. You're talking about like
making the cloud the cloud stuff itself
kind of abstract.
>> Yeah. Like if we abstract it away fully
and like let's say open a cloud made it
impossible for you to understand this
then it actually becomes way harder for
you as an engineer to maximize cloud
code. The reason you can maximize cloud
code is because you can understand
what's happening.
>> Yeah. Um so you go through this and you
go through your context window and let's
say at this point you've you've used up
about um
oh god how do I draw a line? At this
point you've used up maybe like 40% of
your context window. Um, and you can
keep going like this and you can keep
going, but the thing we always talk
about, um, 12 factor agents on the show
all the time is you want to optimize
your context window. And every time you
make a new user message, you're sending
the whole context window to the model.
Every time a tool gets called, you're
sending the whole context window. And so
the longer this gets, the more noise
there is and the less really useful
information is like the the density of
useful information about what is the
right next step gets diluted and diluted
over time. And so, um, while you could
just say like, hey, read all the files,
search for the thing, fix this. Okay, I
did it. Okay, now do this. Now, do this.
Okay, I did it. Um, what what we have
found is like, let me see, sorry, I have
show notes and some other uh some other
things over here. Um, yeah, what we do a
lot of the time is we'll do like what we
call intentional compaction where we'll
kind of take the progress. You can use
the slash compact command. I personally
think it sucks um because it's not just
the information in the prompt, it's also
the trajectory, but we'll get into that
in a sec. Um so what you can do is you
can like send a user message like, you
know, put everything we did
everything we did so far in a markdown
file so that an agent can pick up with
task, right? And so you'll put that into
a file in your repo.
This is like the the the slightly
smarter way.
Um and then you would your first user
message you would clear the context. So
you'd have all your base stuff and then
you'd have user message and you would
say like read this file and then get on
with the plan. Um and so you would it
would the assistant would read the file
And and the premise here, just so
everyone knows, is like it's not just
that you can put the context window
directly into the conversation. What
you're able to do is you can actually
put like a compressed version of the
context window, not even a onetoone copy
of what happened previously.
>> So the thing that file represents when
Dexter is drawing this is actually
represents a compression of all this
state that happened up until now in a
way that the model understands it.
>> Yes. And it's important here that when
you when you tell the model
>> to actually go do this, it's not going
to magically go do this and actually
clear out the context window. This stuff
still lives in this thread. So the only
way you can take advantage of this
technique was actually to stop the
thread and start a new thread
>> with this ability.
>> Yes. Unless
Unless Claude act gives you a specific
tool that it gives the model that says
clear context which is able to go back
and go do this to itself.
>> That slashcompact command is effectively
that
>> that Claude has built.
>> What about
>> Yeah. So, so yeah, go ahead.
>> What about the micro compaction? They
just that gets rid of the tool calls.
They just came out with it like
yesterday.
>> That's what I mean. like they're adding
more and more ways for you as a user to
engineer the to engineer the context
because that is an essential part for
cloud code to success. But it's not just
about it's not just about like any sort
of command. It's just like they want to
give you tools so that you can do a
better job at doing the compaction. And
the best way to think about this is if
you've ever seen like Malik or memory
and you've seen like disc fragmentation
issues. Obviously the computer on
average we don't want to allocate the
disk manually every single time. But at
some point your disc gets super
fragmented and you run a defragger and
it actually will make your disc space
way better allocated. This is kind of
your equivalent of defragging the
context out of here.
>> So you can just like really easily
organize what you're actually sending to
the model.
>> Yeah. And so the the issue with compact
is and and clear and micro compaction
all this stuff. So so clear is really
good. I use clear all the time because
clear is essentially starting you out
with a fresh context window. Clear does
not reset the same. Clear basically
gives you a fresh session with no
context in it and then you can start
from fresh from from a new message.
>> Um compact is designed to be super
general like work for everything. And
just like building agents that work for
everything, like this generic tool
calling loop that is just go call tools
until you're done, while it will work
okay and get you to 80% quickly. Um, if
you want to get the most performance out
of a coding agent, you should be doing
your compaction manually. And you can
prompt it and you can build the file and
then you can edit the file by hand or
you can prompt claude, hey, update this
file some more. Um, but as you get to
what we try to do is we try to target
like maximum 50% context. This doesn't
always become true. Um, but we try to
target maximum like 50% context
utilization because that's that's
generally plenty to do anything that's
good. And I'll walk through kind of our
our process a little bit more
intentional than this. But I'll um and
like what I've seen really really good
vibe coders do is a little bit more
intentional than this. Um, but the idea
of keeping your context window small and
being very intentional about what you
tell the model. This current progress.md
is going to have like path to file line
number
path to file because that way you're not
filling up the context window with a
bunch of search search finding other
things like finding things that are
irrelevant. Once a model looks for
something and finds a bunch of
irrelevant stuff that's in the context
window forever until you compact it. And
so you want to this is also like um a
great opportunity to talk about like how
sub aents work. Um sub aents have
actually been in claude um for a long
time. And if we go back to the trace
this is from a pre sub aents um let's
see task tool. Yeah. So this is a tool
called task. This has been in cloud
since way before the like sub aents
launch uh a couple weeks ago. Um and
this is basically launch a new tool that
has two it's a tool that has two
parameter. description that is what
shows up in the UI and then the prompt
and so this is just launching another
instance of cloud code cloud code system
message encourages it to use this task
for that same reason so there's you can
do frequent compaction that's part of
context control the other thing that you
can do to control your context is use
sub aents and so that's why if you tell
claude
>> find where we um
>> yes before we go super into this I have
an idea Yeah,
>> we should show people the outcome of
what happens out of this. I think you
showed me something kind of cool at the
beginning of this. I think we should
just like show people and then let's go
deep into sub agents right after that.
>> Um
>> I want to show people
>> always trying to change the agenda on
me.
>> Well, I want to show people the real
code that you had and I think that was
like the coolest. Um
>> we're going to get there. We're going to
get there. We're going to get there.
>> All right, go for it.
Um
what we're working backwards from is
basically I don't know Rust very well
and the BAML codebase is incredibly
complex uh because it's a programming
language and the process I'm going to
outline here I used last night and I'll
show you every step. We'll do every step
live as part of this. Um but this is the
process I use to fix a bug in BAML. Um
and at the end we're going to look at
the PRs and I have two separate
implementation paths to compare
different approaches and we're going to
see which one FBO likes better.
real code review feedback.
>> Um, so just on the concept one more
time, if you say something like find
where we load the user data from the
database, you might get a task. And what
a task is, sub aents are not for playing
house. They're not for
anthropomorphizing. They are for exactly
one thing, which is context control. And
so what a task will do will give you a
brand new context window where the user
message, you get all the same system
stuff, but the user message is actually
determined by the model. The parent
model is going to give it a message like
you know find where we load this stuff
and then this thing is going to read
read read. It's usually set usually we
use sub aents mostly for readon stuff.
So it's going to read read search etc
until it finds the thing
and then it's going to return an
assistant message which is pretty tight
which is like that file
that file is in source main whatever.
And so what you get back here is your
tool response is really tight. And so
all of this searching and finding all
those tool calls are never in the main
agents context window. And so if you can
get good at using sub agents, one, they
can run in parallel. So you can say,
"Hey, go find where this happens and
where this happens and where this
happens." But you have to to get this to
happen well, the only people I've seen
do this well and the only way I've found
to do it well is to have your user
message say like use a sub agent and
prompt it like this. And I'll show you
some of our prompts that look like that
are open source
>> because that's how you
>> work well for this kind of task is like
for example
>> uh very recently we just added go
support and we had to write a lot of
unit tests for go support to make sure
it actually worked. Well, once I had it
outlined the spec for all the unit tests
that I had to write and all the file
names that had to go write, I just made
it go write all the go uh unit tests in
parallel. And that was an easy way to do
sub agents because each sub aent was
really responsible or each task was
responsible for each type of test. So
some tests were testing recursive types,
some test were testing unions, some
tests were testing classes and each one
could build its own context window and
maximize the context for that task
individually. And that I found to be
like a really good strategy. It has like
incredible performance wins over
actually doing it in one continuous
thread. It's not just about like speed.
He guess it's faster, but what De says
about accuracy, like I can 100% echo
that.
>> Yeah. And and the goal with all of this
is like can you get it to the point
where this agent can oneshot the the the
task, right? And so you do a lot of
research and get to the point where you
have a plan. Um and so the way the kind
of like intentional steps that we do
here is we have kind of a three-phased
approach which is like research,
planning,
and then like implementation.
And actually like from a both from a uh
both from a like getting the best
performance out of the coding agent and
also like being able to collaborate. I
don't know if anyone's ever seen this um
but you start working on a feature with
a vibe coding agent and the scope just
grows and grows. You're like, "Oh, I'll
fix this too and I'll fix this too." And
like it just gets bigger and bigger
because you're just sitting there and
like, "Well, I'm I already have it. I
already have the context. Agent already
knows everything. Let's just do this,
too."
Um, and to combat that, um, we found
that creating these intentional
checkpoints, um, works really, really
well. So, I'm going to show you our
prompt for research real quick. Um, so
we have all our commands. They're open
source. We use these. We update there's
a couple private ones that we haven't
shared yet, but that like once we like
them, we will we will publish them as
well. This is the research prompt. It's
300 lines of markdown. Um, and we tell
it here's the document you want we want
to pull out. And u, we tell it here's
all the different sub aents and how to
use them and how to prompt them. Um, and
this is mostly written by um, Allison
who is a legendary vibe coder um, and
has built a lot of really dope stuff.
So, shouts out to her. Um, research. So,
our research is going to be again the
same thing. We have this prompt
and then we have a long user message,
right? that that that cloud slash
command is like pretty long, but that's
okay. We're it's worth it. We're like
tuning this to make sure we get the
right context window. And so what this
is going to do is it's going to launch a
bunch of sub aents to go look at
different parts of the codebase. And I'm
going to go kick one of these off right
now just so you can see what it looks
like. Um so I'm going to create one in
AI that works slash um which one is it?
What are we? 08.
>> Mhm.
>> Search codebase. Um, and actually what
I'm going to do is I'm going to pull up
the BAML issue that we are working on.
So, this is something that's been open
for a while. Uh, basically an issue in
BAML where if you put an at assertion in
um,
uh, I'm not going to show off why this
is broken. Maybe I'll come back to it.
Um,
>> it basically, you can take my word for
it. It is a real bug uh, that has been
open since December.
>> Yeah. So if you have a test like this
where it's like okay you're asking the
model to output hello world and you
assert that it equals hello fu you will
get no warning and this test will pass
because this is meaningless. But if you
have two ats in your assert then the
test will fail. And so now so like you
could have tests that you thought you
wrote and have no idea that they're
failing silently. So I basically took
this in um find everywhere in dot dot
dot dotbaml
relevant
to solving this issue and figure out how
the information flows. Um these take a
little bit of steering like the prompt
itself is not you know foolproof. Um and
then I'm just going to paste this in and
I'm going to launch a new session and
we'll see that this is going to launch a
bunch of sub aents. Um, I'm going to let
this run for a sec, um, while I'm
drawing out what's happening. So, this
will launch a bunch of different sub
aents to research different things.
These sub aents can also research the
web, but these are going to do most of
the work. Um, and they're all going to
have their own context window and their
own specific prompt. And then we're
going to pull this back to uh basically
have a big write call where the agent's
going to write out a you know two to 400
line file that is like the research
about this.
>> Um and that'll
>> point and the whole mechanism that's
driving that is that one Dextra is
trying to be as hands off on this
codebase as possible because one he
doesn't know the codebase. So what he
really wants to do is like rather than
manually even telling the person to do
this, he's just going to instead of like
saying like, "Oh, this task is probably
easy." Like if you go for me, my
perspective, I know exactly what lines
of code I have to touch. Dex has no
idea. So, what he should do, he's he's
like shortcutting the agent's work and
saying like before you before I even
tell you to fix it, just identify
anything that could potentially be
better because then when I actually go
look and understand what might be
necessary to fix it instead of me
instead of the agent both trying to fix
it and discover everything, the
discovery problem is solved at that
point.
>> Yeah. And even if you were going to
build a plan and implement it by hand by
going into cursor or Vim and making the
changes, this can be super valuable to
tell me, hey, here's the files you need
to be looking at.
>> And we have in the repo here. Okay, so
this is
>> it's effectively the same work that Dex
would be doing if I were to sit with him
for 20 minutes and onboard him. Like
this is literally what
>> show me where are the files.
>> You probably have to touch roughly these
files and this is the idea that you
would want to really go and touch play
around with.
>> Yeah. So, this one's using a lot of uh
GP and blob and stuff which tend to
require permissions. But yeah, this is
searching for this. Um, I'm actually
going to stop this and say stop
run the agents in parallel. And you
still have to steer some steer some of
this stuff to only use read glob gp
search never bash because bash requires
permission and I know it can find this
stuff using the built-in tools.
>> Yep. Um,
>> and this just where like just knowing
that the fact that these tools exist
just makes Dex better at this and faster
at this because he's like, "Ah, rather
than me approving the manual, I'll just
try and force it to not use mash
>> again." And knowing all this stuff is
understanding how the tools look and how
it is prompted. So, it's like, yeah, GP
first fast pattern search based on based
on RIP GP or whatever. Um, I don't know
if it's still based on RG, but um, if we
come in here to research, I can show you
the document that was created when I did
this last night. So, we're not going to
wait for it to go do the whole thing.
Um, but here, yeah, BAML test
assertions, assert versus assert, and it
says here's where the issue is. The
parser accepts both things. And most
importantly, it's giving us the names of
the files. So, the next agent that's
going to work on this, whether it's
building a plan or jumping straight to
implementation, knows exactly where to
look and what lines to look at. And so,
this is really, really powerful.
>> So, you can see how like this is clearly
going to make any implementation plan
just like way fewer tool calls.
Exactly. And so the tool you want to get
to the
>> you want to get to the writing and yeah
go ahead. Sorry.
>> What I'm say the tool call you can make
is literally just exactly this. It's
read this file at these line numbers.
That's an exact tool call already
defined in claude. That is like 10 times
less work than anything else the agent
would be doing.
>> Yeah. And so we go even a little bit
further. And so what's also cool is like
we think about this in a hierarchy,
right? So like a bad line of code is a
bad line of code. A bad line in an imple
implementation plan if there's like a
mistake in how to implement something
could be 10 or 100 line bad lines of
code. A bad line of research like a
misunderstanding of how the system works
or where functionality is located can
lead you to a thousand bad lines of
code. And then of course your like core
prompting set is which is how you like
manage your research and your building
implementation plans and things like
that can actually lead to a 100,000 bad
lines of code. um if you're if you're
not actually your core building blocks.
And so what we do when we're building is
we focus human attention on the highest
leverage stuff. So everybody reviews the
research and in our linear board we
literally have like research in
progress, research in review before it
goes to ready to plan. And so we spend a
lot more time reviewing the research and
the plan and keeping a shared
understanding of the system than we do
actually like reviewing the
implementation itself and the code. I
read what I read really closely in
implementation is the tests. And so if
the tests are passing and the tests are
well designed, I have high confidence in
the code that it's at least like
somewhat well architected and that it's
going to and that it's going to solve
the problem.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and we do regular like architecture
reviews and co tech deck cleanups too.
>> Yeah. And the problem and the I think
the premise here is like for those of
you that have ever worked like principal
engineers or senior staff engineers or
distinguished engineers, it's always the
same. like the distinguished engineer
doesn't actually have to be writing the
code, but as long as they sign off on
the design, it's probably correct. I
think that's the only thing that you
have to do here. And like it's it's a
hard practice to do because most people
sometimes forget to be really detail-
oriented in that part of the plan.
That's the trick.
>> Yeah.
>> But doing that is what you got to do. If
you're not doing that, you're slowing
down. And Pete just said exactly what I
was going to say.
Um, and so we'll look at we'll look at
the planning next, but the plan is very
similar. It's instructions on how to
build a phase by phase plan.
>> Do you want to show
>> implementation plan?
>> Yes. So, I'll show in a sec the plan
that got made. Um,
see, so there's two of these actually.
So, let me let me just talk about talk
through kind of what what I did just to
for what we're comparing is I actually
ended up um Oops. Let's see if we can
find this.
Uh,
I actually got impatient because the
research actually like the research was
wrong a couple times. I had to like
delete it, throw it out and resteere it
a couple times because the first one
that came back said it's perfectly
solved. It already supports this today
and like you don't need to worry about
this. And so I had to steer it a little
bit and I had to like basically go back
to the issue, write up this failing test
case and so that it would be able to
actually find the right thing. And so
those are learnings and like none of
this is foolproof and you have to adapt
it to your codebase and to whatever kind
of mood Opus is in throughout the day.
But I actually so I made I made a
research
>> and just and while Dexter is going to
type out some diagrams just to call out
here like the reason Dasher could
actually throw out that research is
twofold. One he actually reads a
research. He doesn't just throw it away.
A lot of people just throw it away.
>> Yes. Read it.
>> You have to read your [__] Do not do
not make a plan and send it to your
co-workers if you didn't read it yet.
>> Exactly. And then two, the other thing
is like Dexter to some degree knows the
user experience that he expects. He
knows this is broken for sure. So it's
like the axiom that he's working off of
is somewhat true. Like he knows it must
be false because he's tried using it and
the feature is broken.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's possible that since December
was fixed and we didn't update the
GitHub issue, but he also knows that
it's false because he's tried it and he
knows that that feature is still broken.
>> Yeah. And this is also where like you
need to get creative a little bit. So,
like step one, I wrote this journal
down. We'll publish this as well. It's
like I did a bad research. Uh, and I
actually threw out the file because it
kept confusing the later ones, but I'll
go find it um and put it back in here.
Um, but I basically uh I refined. So, I
saw the research was wrong and it said
there's no bug. I updated the spec with
that test case and then I resteered the
research and I actually what I said was
like here's the issue. Give me back a
research prompt so that the next person
who tries this will not [__] it up. And
so it gave me back this huge prompt of
like here's the problem and here's the
test cases and all this stuff. And then
on my second research I pasted this in
and I said research the codebase which
took my big command here and then I gave
it as like what do you want to research
all of this content. And so like there
is value to understanding and you can
still take that broken research context
and turn it into something useful that
is compacted down of and then you start
from scratch again with your manually.
So this was an instance of like manual
compaction that I used to kick off the
research again.
>> And if you want to go back to one more
thing I want to talk about
>> is the thing I want everyone to think
about here is like the only reason that
this can also be happen and this is an
important part of building software now
is if you're not thinking about like
common nomenclature and using the same
names across your code bases you're
going to mess up the system because like
for example we clearly call these field
and block attributes and they are called
the same thing everywhere in the
codebase. There's not a single place in
the codebase where you don't refer to
this as an attribute or there's not a
another thing that is magically called
attribute that is slightly different. So
if you have a codebase that randomly
renamed things and you only renamed half
of it, you're [__] yourself and you
need to go and fix that because a model
can't do the right thing if you have
seven different
um seven different ways to refer to it.
So like not only are you making it hard
for humans, you're also making hard for
agentic systems.
Yes, words are important. Code is
>> words are more important than ever
before.
>> Yeah. Um, okay, cool. So, this one's
continuing to do research and stuff. Um,
I'm going to just approve these. This is
a this is a this is an example of how
this stuff can work. Um, let's see.
Okay.
Uh,
but where were we? Sorry. Um, that's
that's great. We're going to show the
plan.
>> So, I did two things, right? So I I took
this research, I threw it in the trash.
I took this research and I started a
plan. I also got annoyed because the
research was taking too long. So I tried
to just create a plan with no research
to see if that would work too. Because
what you can probably do for small
issues is like during the planning
process, it's also going to go do some
research on the codebase. And so for
really big really complex things where
like if this thing has to research
everything it might push it to the like
you know 80% of the context window at
which point your written plan is like
not going to work basically like if this
thing doesn't find what it wants in the
first six sub agents then it's going to
run you know six more sub aents and then
your context window is getting kind of
bad and your plan's going to be low
quality. Um sometimes you can just plan
if it's a simple thing you can create a
plan and skip the research phase. Um and
we've done that. So, I I actually wanted
to try this for this feature cuz I
wanted to build a sense for it. This is
also like what Vibb always talks about
is like getting lots of reps. The more
reps you can get on this stuff, the
better intuition. What's the thing you
said about like the ML engineer who just
like put his thumb in the air or
something?
>> Well, yeah. It's all just vibes.
Everything is just like which direction
is the wind blowing? I don't know. It
depends on the day.
>> Yeah, it's hard to tell.
>> How is How is Opus feeling today? Um,
>> exactly.
>> Uh, you're absolutely right, man. So uh
what we what we'll do here is uh there's
two plans here. So this one was made
with the research. So I waited for the
research to finish and then I did the
plan and then I did the implementation.
And this one I just launched the plan.
And I just said, you know, here I I I
pasted that exact same big prompt that
we pasted into the second research. And
I um find this thing, this whole big
prompt of like, hey, here's how would
you look into this? And I just pasted
that into the plan command. And the plan
command is very specific around um and
like your plan command should basically
like, you know, you have step one, which
is figuring learn still you still have
to refill the context window with all
the files and things like that. Um, and
then you're going to discover how things
work. Um, but then you build the plan.
Um, and this one's even prompted to work
back and forth with the user to propose,
hey, here's what the phases are and then
basically like build out a phased uh,
implementation plan. And so we'll look
at these.
>> So, by the way, before we go into the
plan, I just want to tell everyone when
I go skim that research just as someone
that knows the codebase, I look at that
research that Dex has, I'm like, this
looks correct.
>> It's like 120 lines. Just skimming it. I
know those files by heart and I know
those are the right files to look at. So
now let's go look at the plan and I I'll
give you my gut instinct on whether or
not I thought it was good or not.
>> Okay, we're going to look at the no
research one first. Um so yeah, here's
how it works. You have your BAML block
attributes. Um tester parses value
expression blocks. Um the parser is
here. The validation gap is missing in
visit test case. That actually sounds I
I don't know anything about BAML, but I
know a lot about parsers, and that
sounds about right for the uh
>> that's a visitor for a test case.
>> Yeah. Um so what's cool about the plan
also is you can prompt to say like, hey,
here's what we're not doing. Um because
this is really valuable when you give
this to the implementation agent. It
steers it to stay away from trying. A
lot of times cloud will be like, oh
yeah, I also added this and I also added
this and I also added postquantum
cryptography or whatever the hell
emergent thing that it wants to drop in.
Um but yeah, so we add field attribute
validation to test block. So this is it.
This is saying go to configuration.rs
and make this change.
>> Um which is like adding
>> this is not just good. This is a great
error message on top of that. Uh on top
of that
>> um and that's phase one. And then it has
like hey here's how to do the automated
checks. And I actually didn't do any
manual verification because I don't know
how to spin up my local version of BAML
and install it in VS Code. But uh we
skipped that part. So we'll see when we
get to the code review phase. Um, and
then it talked about what test to add.
Um, so your prompt should all you should
always prompt the model to add tests.
And actually what I'm doing lately is I
have a new version of this prompt which
is like the phases should be always
write a failing test and then fix it.
And that way you have as many
checkpoints as you can. I mean obviously
the idea is with a really good
implementation plan written by experts
who know the codebase well. You the
implementation is almost always very
straightforward and you can once you can
put it on auto accept and you can come
back when it's done.
Um
>> what I have what I have found is exactly
what VJ is saying is like I only do TDD
with agents. It is the only in my
opinion I I have a very strong opinion
on it is the only way to write uh AI
generated code AI generated code. Um and
I pretty much I the first thing I do is
I make it write tests before I let it
write any other code. And what I do
specifically even further is we actually
have done work in the BMA codebase to
make write running and eval test way
easier than it should be because if it's
not then it doesn't work. Uh because the
system that you actually have like the
test commands you use they need to be
really trivial for the LM to run and it
needs to be able to run just like any
sort of test case trivially. So for
example, this test is called like test
multiple args of test multiple invalid
argriets and test that thing should be
like it should be obvious to the LM
exactly how it's going to go run.
>> Yep. I like it. So anyways, any anything
in this plan so far that's standing out
to you is wrong?
>> No. Like I I would honestly be like like
maybe there there might be nuances that
are wrong, but the fir the scan that I'm
looking for in my mind is what are the
error messages? Do the error messages
look good? Because that's important
because human readability is an end
outcome that I would measure on. And
like what test is it adding
>> everything else like I'm like skimming.
I'm like is it roughly touching
approximately the right files and it
looks approximately correct.
>> Okay.
>> So like I'm like okay
>> that I think that's one thing that's the
same around all really good people who
are really good at using these tools is
they they focus a lot on how can we
build automated ways for the model to
know that it's correct. And so like if
the tests are well designed and you've
given the model a good harness in which
it can iterate and test and make sure
that it's that it's that it's working
well and you steer it to focus on making
sure the tests are correct and then
fixing the code afterwards, you can get
really good results with being totally
hands off while it's implementing.
>> Exactly.
>> Um okay, cool. This is the one made with
no research. The one made with research
is actually much shorter, which is
interesting because maybe that's a sign
that the research was uh let's see. So,
here's basically the same change that we
saw in the other one, which is in the
visitor. This is like the fact that I
saw this in both plans is a good sign to
me that like this is the exact actual
fix.
Um, and then it's adding a validation
test case. So, it's like the way it
describes the test is actually like
quite different. And I'm guessing that
this is probably because it read more of
the files about how the unit tests work.
>> This is the right way to write tests in
our repo for this type of system. Uh the
other test case would actually be
incorrect. Uh not incorrect sense. Like
if it did this, I would later tell it
not to do this and I'd be like go do
this other thing later. The research
one,
>> you reject the PR and you would say do
it this way.
>> I would.
>> Yeah. Okay, cool. So there's there's the
there's the big difference. Um, but
anyways, what I did after that was I
took both plans and handed them to
agents and we're not going to go to get
work trees or how we interact with
GitHub API and stuff because I don't
think we have time. We can maybe save
that for the Q&A if there's time. But we
ran these in two separate directories,
both plans in parallel. And um, we got
out these two PRs.
So, um, this is the one from with
research and this is the one with no
research. And I'm curious, actually, I
haven't really looked in depth at these
um, but we're going to look at these
together.
Um, it looks like we have that fixed
that we saw in both plans. And then you
have the tests being updated as probably
as expected.
>> So these are the tests. These are
correct. And then we can just see if it
Oh, it's it's merging. I guess it passed
all the tests.
>> Oh, sick.
>> Yeah.
>> I didn't realize you had you have
automatic you have automatic merge cues.
>> Yeah. Well, I approved this one. I I
didn't actually run. I guess the test
must have passed. Oh, yeah. Aaron does
merge.
>> Oh, and Aaron didn't even know I was
doing this PR as a bit. Yeah, Aaron had
no idea that he was in this. He just
merged it because the test passed and
like we know what it means for the test
to pass. These tests are good tests.
They will work.
>> Nice. Let's see this one.
>> Um like
>> this one didn't get reviewed.
>> Yeah. So you should close this one. This
is incorrect.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, this is the research file test.
>> Yeah, it eventually during the
implementation it figured it out that
this was how to do tests.
>> Um
>> okay, that probably tells me one thing.
The way we designed a repo is not
totally absurd. If both models figured
it out, even if it had the wrong way.
Um, but yeah, this
>> this one's interesting.
>> This has the config thing in it. It's
like implemented differently. It's it's
changed actually a different file.
>> Um, it's
it's the same thing. Uh, there's like
two different ways to do it.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> Yeah, the other way is better.
>> Okay, cool. So, yeah, we'll close this
one. Uh, but yeah, that's I mean that's
kind of the core of it. Let me jump back
to the list and see if there's anything
else I wanted to talk about. Um, the
biggest takeaway I think the Vibop said
that I want to like hash on a lot is you
have to read the [__] that the model
spits out and you can either iterate
with the model on like that plan's not
right. I want to change the order of the
phases or like hey make sure there's
tests first or you can literally go I do
this a lot. I spend a lot again like the
direction of leverage is like this the
stuff over on the left is the highest
leverage and so I am always looking
really closely at you know how at this
kind of stuff and I might even change it
manually if it if the model can't get it
I might even change it manually be like
the tests are here change this test
here's a failing test sometimes I'll
even write the failing test for it um
but this gives you also like one thing I
love to talk about in coding and code
review I don't know if you've seen this
one Um
uh this guy Blake Smith that I used to
work with who wrote an article on code
review. Um the most important thing
about code review is not design or
correct or finding bugs. The most
important thing is mental alignment is
keeping people on the same page about
how the system is changing as it
evolves.
And this is a big like principal
engineer kind of thing. And so the specs
process means that even if I don't
review the code, I read the spec. And
the spec is way easier. The the 200line
spec or 300 line implementation plan is
way easier for me to review and grock
and understand than a GitHub PR where
all the code is out of order and I don't
actually know which order you made the
changes in and it's kind of logic. It's
just alphabetical instead of like being
stacked in the order that you did it. Um
so this is really like one of the like
ancillary benefits of working in this
way and how really big teams work like
saying yeah the principal engineer signs
off on the design and then it goes to
implementation he doesn't care anymore
>> but he has understand they have
understanding of how how things are
changing
>> and I'm show like in our code base for
example there are parts of there are
parts of the code like for example we do
no code reviews in our whole team even
with AIdriven development the reason we
don't do them is because we write pretty
damn good tests and we put a lot of
infrastructure of writing good test
suites. But there are some parts of the
codebase that are really really really
really nuanced and we do need like two
or three people to read them for a
couple reasons. One, they're just
algorithmic algorithmically complex and
two there's just not enough test
coverage and we have a proxy for that as
a team for where that is. So we just use
apply process as necessary accordingly.
And we found that to be a great system.
And like it's the same with AI agents.
Like if you're going to use an agent to
go write code, you need to treat it in
that way where it's like you have to
mentally build a model for like what's a
boundary for what it can do and what it
can't do. What parts of your codebase
are already [__] up and you should
probably not let it loose. What parts of
your codebase are really well hygiened
and you can let it kind of do whatever
because it'll probably do the right
thing.
Yeah, that makes sense. And like having
a sense and that's the kind of thing
that like you can eventually start to
feed that instinct to the model through
your claw MD or through your base
prompts or through your steering. But
like the things that we validate the
most are like if someone wants to change
one of these, this impacts every line of
code in our codebase. And so before we
change this, we don't just review the
code. We have everybody pull down the
new version and use it for a couple days
in their day-to-day work before we let
that change roll out because it's like
changing your CI/CD or changing your
cloud provider. It's so fundamental to
everything in our product and every way
that we make progress that a regression
in one of these could cause a hundred
regressions within within a
>> I have a question. Do you think you're
will do you think you're able to share a
conbon board of how you look at
research?
>> Yeah, we'll we'll pull that up. We'll
pull that up. Um I have a combo board
which is for our
>> Yeah. So this is um by the way this is
the human layer repo. This is where we
work on a number of things including our
like open- source terminal UI for
managing lots of cloud codes. Um and I
actually go
>> if I go I'm going to show you kind of
how the implementation plan looks as
well. Um,
BAML
slash. Um, yeah. So, if we do the one
with the research,
um,
copy. When you showed this, I was
furiously googling where this came from
and then I found your repo eventually.
>> Yeah.
>> Everyone's like, "Dex, what are you
working on?" And I'm like, "You could
find it. It's just uh it's completely in
the open, but we're not we're not really
talking about it just yet."
>> Um, yeah. I think this is one of the
coolest UXes that I've seen to actually
manage like multiple cloud codes. So
like if someone's like a super user, I
think it'd be interesting for them to
try it. Um
um while Dex does this um questions from
people I think I think today's episode
is really about like conversations
around how to go do this. Like we built
a real PR. We got it merged. I actually
had not seen the PR until Dex told me
like two minutes before the call I did
this and I saw a notification for the PR
going through. He's like, "Can you
approve this?" I was like, "What the
heck?" Um, but like honestly like people
should be using more AI for everything.
And like part of that is you should be
teaching yourself how to maximize
context window at any given time. And
that might be a change in process. It
might be a change in like testing
design. It might be a change in the way
you're just naming your file systems
along the way or your files along the
way. But like if you're not actively
thinking about it and you're just like
vibing it fully, don't do it. Don't do
that. You're just shooting yourself in
the foot. Like hoping is a really really
bad strategy. It's like hiring a bunch
of junior engineers or even hiring a
bunch of senior engineers that have no
context on what you're doing and just
telling them to go build 50,000
features. They will, but it probably
won't align with what you want even if
they're really really good engineers.
And that's just like a fundamental way
of like how software does like
transitioning and understanding what
both people have like doing the
intellect transition or the handoff of
like here's what I know here's what you
know like building the bridge for how
you communicate that's the magic behind
all of this.
>> Yeah. Um also here's a fun trick. If you
tell Claude to think deeply you get the
thinking tokens. This can backfire. Uh
you don't always want more thinking.
There's a I don't Has anyone ever used
ultraink?
>> What?
>> Yeah sucks. Uh most of the time it's
like
>> yeah it's uh it pays it makes it really
good at paying attention to things
higher up in the conversation but
sometimes you like change your you say
hey we're not doing it that way and ult
on a previous instruction.
>> Yeah.
>> So anyways this is the agent going
through the plan. Yeah. Jensen, what's
up?
>> Oh uh my question was uh sorry I was uh
listening too deeply. Sorry I forgot I
raised my hand. I was going to ask it.
Yeah, I know. I was I read your command
literally, I guess, uh or your your
prompt technique uh for sharing things.
I guess like you know, one thing that is
hard for some people might be that they
don't they're not they're literally not
allowed to use any of the things you're
using basically for their work, but they
also need to work with AI tools. And I
find that many people have no experience
with these tool tools outside of work
because they're too busy working to
learn anything. Any suggestion?
>> I think you want to go first.
>> Let me I'm just gonna share an article.
Um this is a guy.
>> No, I already got it. It's too late.
>> Okay.
>> Uh Jeff is uh works on AMP, which is the
source code coding CLI. He posted this
article back in June. Like coding with
LM is like an instrument. You need just
like any other coding, just like any
other like software craft, any craft,
>> you you need to practice and you need to
learn. And uh if you can't do it at
work, you need to find time to do it
outside of work. Um because the people
who are getting really really good at
this are uh I think my favorite thing uh
Jeff has said to me is like a lot of
people running a marathon and some of
them are about to get passed by people
riding motorcycles and they're not going
to know what to do about it. So you got
to go got to go uh find the parking lot
on the weekend and go spin the
motorcycle around a little bit.
>> I have subscriptions to all the
expensive ones. So
>> there you Well, I think another way
another thing I think is like people
assume that they can't do this at work
for a variety of reasons and they're
like, "Ah, I'm I'm stuck using Gemini or
I just use Azure models instead of using
cloud code or something else." But in
reality, I think most companies at this
point have allowed some level of AI in
their workplace. And even if it's just
using chat GBT at the very least, let's
just go with the very basic example.
It's not very efficient, but the
practices that we're talking about here
are apply everywhere. Whenever you copy
and paste stuff in the chat GPT,
whenever you go and like use cursor to
go write some code, the same principles
apply. Choosing when you clear your
context window, adding a research step
before you actually go and implement
your actual system. Like all of these
steps are just processes that you have
to go think about. And even even the
steps that we're proposing here today,
like I don't think Dex would be the one
to claim that like this process is like
the best. it's foolproof. This is the
way to go. 100% do this. Like it's just
about process discovery and like keeping
your mind open to being like what I need
to constantly do is re-evaluate what I'm
doing. I think one of the most stressful
parts about software engineering as a
whole is that the hardest thing about
software is you have to keep learning
new things. Like you don't stop. You're
like we went on from like being like oh
you could build C++ terminal
applications. Then you have to build
gueies in native desktop. Then you have
to go learn how to build websites. Then
you learn how to build backends in
Python. Then you learn pandas and numpy
to do various types of machine learning.
And all these things are just more and
more things we had to go learn along the
way. But like now the problem is now we
have to adapt our process of learning
all the time. And learning how to learn
is just a hard skill set. But just start
do anything any amount of AI you use.
Just be ask yourself that question every
single time like what could be better
this time? And like just try things.
Like don't be afraid to like change up
your process 10% of the time. Write a
different prompt 10% of the time. Change
whether you put your question first or
your context first half the time. Like I
do I've been sampling with that. Do I
put the file first or do I put the
question first? At some point I
empirically discovered that putting the
question second just led to better
results. So I just
>> and the people who are the best at this
and like the people who uh I
collaborated with on making these plans
and these prompts and stuff are people
who spend all day using Claude like yes
even if it's slower and like I we've
embraced this too and like after after a
month or so you start to like at at
first you'll be slower you'll be like
[__] I could have just gone and done
this in cursor and this is taking too
long but it's worth the invest. It's
just like if you were a great Python
developer and you try to learn C, like
yeah, you're going to suck and it's
going to take you way longer to do the
things you used to be able to do, but
once C is a bad example. Let's say if
you're a C developer, I don't think that
would be worth learning, but yes,
>> let's go the other way. Let's say if
you're if you're a C++ person, you got
to learn Python and you're like, I can't
do this.
>> Okay. All right. All right.
>> I mean, I I found that I'm using
languages that I haven't fully learned,
but I understand enough to use the
language. So that's basically it. And uh
I mean and what you're saying is yeah
that's essentially the path I figured
out. The hardest thing was
>> trying to figure out how I learn
basically that was really the hardest
part and you know if I go back to
college time like I didn't really I you
know I had one degree in business and I
notetaking wasn't a thing and then in
computer science I didn't really do
notes I just did computer science. For
most people, what I recommend is most
people have don't have the context or
the bandwidth, like both emotional and
mental bandwidth to just like learn
things all the time. It's just tiring to
be honest.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I do two things. One, I just
replicate what other people do that I
like. And two, I just add some process
in there that's bounded that helped me
go do this in a naturally explorative
way. So, for example, for our engineers,
I generally recommend everyone try cloud
code for the first 10 minutes of a task.
If at the end of those 10 minutes you
feel like you will conclude on a happy
path within 30 minutes, keep doing it.
If you don't, go back and do it your old
way. But it's a really nice framework
that isn't absolute that can always be
used. So you don't you don't your brain
doesn't have to think about it. You just
go do it.
>> One tweak to that is I would say yeah,
if you're 10 minutes in and it's not
working,
>> start over and try for another 10
minutes and then go do it again.
>> At some point you kind of want to just
go write some code and get it done with
and move on with the feature. And it's a
balance. Like if I'm a senior drones,
[__] dude. If I'm a staff level, I just
I just want to ship the thing and move
on to the thing that I actually want to
work on.
>> Yeah. But if you shoot a half court, if
you shoot a hot half court shot and you
miss, but you see that you're off to the
left. If you immediately try to shoot
another one, you will learn faster than
if you just shoot one a day
>> because it's like muscle memory. It's
like the action of the learning a
Yeah. But anyway, the premise is the
same. I agree.
>> This is fantastic.
>> All we got question from Pete.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I wanted and we might not
have enough time to talk about but it be
it'd be good to hear a little bit about
how you kind of like set up good
feedback loop for for the agent like as
it's coding like like hey uh the you
know don't forget to run tests setting
up linting rules stuff like that. One of
one of the things that I've noticed is
if I drop clawed code into a codebase
that I haven't really done that much AI
coding with, it tends to write a bunch
of code that's just isn't going to lint
or like the typeing is going to fail and
I'm sitting there in the IDE like
saying, "Dude, there's a lot of red
squigglies there, but Claude code
doesn't get the red squiggly." So, yeah,
it would be good to know if there's any
kind of like power moves that that you
can share.
>> Two tips that I have seen.
>> Oh, go ahead.
>> No, you go first.
>> Um, two tips I've seen. One, open cloud
code in the integrated terminal. Don't
open in a separate terminal. If you do
it through the integrated terminal and
you download a cloud code VS code
extension, you get ID extensions which
give which gives it the LSP errors. If
you're not doing that, shoot yourself.
>> Is it actually getting like the LSP?
>> There is a tool in there that says get
ID extension. Get get uh LSP errors and
it'll get the LSP errors from there.
>> Maybe sometimes you have to prompt it to
use it, but yeah, it is like a a really
big improvement.
>> Yes. So one do that. Two if what
language are you using? Python,
TypeScript, Ruby, Java, Go, C++, like
what's the language?
>> Um, mostly TypeScript and Python.
>> Okay. If you're using TypeScript, if
you're using Python, select the
interpreter in VS Code that is the
correct interpreter like actually select
>> that has the right libraries and stuff.
>> Exactly. Because they don't always
exist. So you're not getting type
checking. Two, turn on type checking for
Python. Python does not have typeeing
turned on by default. Turn it on. So
like for example, let's see if I have
one
cursor. So like if you're in Python py
I'll just open one and you go down here
like my interpreter is not selected.
This because it's a build tool so it
doesn't really matter.
>> The other thing that's not turned on is
like I actually need to go here and like
turn on type checking to on and then
you'll get good typeing errors. So
that's like a really really small
practical thing that you can go do.
That'll just make your Python code
development better. For TypeScript
you're going to end up with something
similar. You want to make sure if you're
using bun, npm, whatever you're using,
your commands in your package.json file
should be exactly the same. They should
all use bun. They should all use npm. I
see sometimes people with pmppm code
bases with npm commands in there. It's
not that it's bad. It's just like now as
a model like okay, which one do I use?
When
>> you're using
>> the other thing you can do is
>> go ahead.
>> You can you can and a model can can
build this into a plan really easily.
Um, if you go I have a one plan here,
but I want to find the brew.
Yeah, the nightly releases thing. So, in
in updating our build process, I it gave
me this plan. Um, and it gave me the
automated verification steps and like
that's all great. Um,
oh, this might not be the right one. Um,
but basically like if you're building a
plan, you can literally give it uh give
it the shell command. you be like make
sure the shell commands have after each
file run this command, run this command,
run this command because then as the
model's going through the plan and using
its to-do list, um it's going to go
through and do that. And like might like
this one has, you know, automated
verification. That's that's not great. A
better version of this plan would say ls
this thing and see what's in there. It
would give the model exact instructions
on how to verify its work.
>> Um you can also use cloud code hooks
>> you can go ahead put a lot of that in
the cloud MD, right?
like
>> you put in the cloudmd.
>> Yes.
>> But I'm going to show you something that
is uh a lot of people don't know. Uh
there is instruction
in Yeah. important. This context may or
may not be relevant to your task. You
should not respond to this context or
otherwise consider in your response
unless it is highly relevant to your
task. Most of the time it is not
relevant. And then and then this is
literally what it says after your cloud
MD. In your cloud MD it gets injected at
the end with a message. this might not
be relevant to everything you're doing.
That's a UX thing because most people
don't know how to write a good cla MD.
>> So if you really want the model to do
something, put it in your plan or better
yet put it exactly directly in your
prompt.
>> Um
>> yeah, and then lastly, what I find is
honestly you're just shooting yourself
in the foot by using bad tools most of
the time. Not you specifically, but most
people are not using good bad tools. So
for example, I use Cargo, we use Rust
for everything.
I have never seen a claw system not run
cargo test while I'm doing it. It
doesn't it doesn't not run claw check or
cargo check. It runs all my llinters and
all my tests automatically for me
>> because Rust by default has a huge test
driven uh TDD type of workflow. If
you're using TypeScript and you're not
using like something like Turbo to do
like your build systems and your
dependency checking, you're right,
you're going to have a hard time telling
cloud code what to build in what order
for a massive workspace,
right? And I think all these problems
get easier if you have small repos. So I
think the only scale which it's worth
talking about is talking about like
giant giant code bases. If you have se
if you have your code across seven
different repos and you're not using a
monor repo, you're right, you will have
a hard time making stuff work. So like I
think it's small things like that that
are actually what the bottleneck of most
systems are. So for example, we don't
have a full monor repo. Bam is a monor
repo but our cloud system is not in the
monor repo. So how do we deal with this?
Well the way we deal with this is our
cloud system it actually works as a
monor repo because we sim link from a
local directory from the baml repo into
there that allows us to pretend like
it's a monor repo. you might want to use
hard links instead because there are
rules about if something is get ignored
or a sim link the cloud search tools
won't traverse it
>> but if you do hard links then it'll work
>> but you can also do something that
something that we do let me show you I'm
going to show you one one more thing uh
actually two more things because I said
I would share a workflow as well
>> um but if you look in this thing and
I'll publish this as well you can put in
your settings.json JSON, you can add
additional directories and then claude
will be able to work and write in those
directories without you can also do this
on the command line. You could do it
during a session, but if you know
everybody on your team is going to be
using two repos, if you open cloud in
one repo, you should give it permission
to go do stuff in the other repo.
>> Yeah. So, like there's just small things
that everyone can do that I think would
dramatically improve their workflows,
but it's mostly just like use the right
tools. And actually like like one of our
uh Chris on our team spent over two
weeks redoing our repo to make the
package.json work with Turbo. It did a
couple things. One, it makes onboarding
for new people easier. Uh so like anyone
else going to contribute can have a
waste your time. They just run like top
level Turbo commands for everything. But
two, it turns out the other thing it
really does makes it way easier for
cloud code and other AI agents to like
get up and running because they just
don't have to think about everything.
They just like run these commands along
the way. And that would be like building
good on it's like basically just
focusing on onboarding for the brand new
engineer who shows up every time you
like type SLC clear.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah.
>> And just like like what what do you wish
you had when you started the system and
like all the tech that things that you
handwave before because you're like ah
it's just oral legend it's good enough.
>> Some of those stuff might be worth
investing in earlier than you think. I
think I had this revelation when you
guys were talking about the the sub
aents and the tasks is that like unless
you've got really nailed down claude MD
and and and tools and all the rest of
it, it's not even like when you start a
new Claude session, it's every time it
does a subtask or it does a sub agent
you it does anything that you've told it
in that session is lost, which is good,
right? less context, like less kind of
stuff to confuse it. But it also means
it's like again it's like turning to
another brand new hire who just walked
in 10 seconds ago and saying, "Hey,
>> figure out why this test isn't working."
And so it has Yeah.
>> For example, one of the things I hate
about Nex.js is everything is called
page.csx.
>> It is impossible.
It is structurally impossible for cloud
code to navigate that.
>> In our in our you see a lot of mod. RS
files because like that's how we used to
write Rust code. But honestly, I try and
not do that anymore. I try and just do
the like folder namer RS for that same
reason because naturally searching for
it is really good.
>> I have another thing.
>> Go ahead.
>> For what it's worth, I mean, you still
have your like file path based stuff in
your next app. Um, and I've spent like
the past two weeks putting together some
demos for a customer on like a Nex.js JS
codebase that's pretty non-trivial now.
And I found that like Claude does
navigate well, but it helps to tell it
like, you know, like in in context.
There's like a little tree view of like
where things are and and like what
they're for. And so like I have a name
for this. I'm like, well, this is the
walkthrough details view. This is the
walkthrough list view. And so like it
understands that. But I mean, I've like
cloud shipped probably 8,000 lines of
code on it in the past couple days for
me. And like I haven't had a problem
with it. It's just one of those things
where like
>> unique frameworks will have like unique
like quirks that you have to like come
up with your own little like context
engineering approach to like solve or to
manage well but it's not like a
fundamental limitation. It's just
something you have to like work around.
>> Yeah. I think the point that I'm making
is like if you're a builder building for
builders these things didn't used to
matter before but they matter now.
>> Like like you're right it is you can do
a little bit more work and get find the
right page.tsx CSX. But like for
example, if you do a tree view of like a
folder structure, I'll share my screen
again
CD repos site. Like if I do tree over
here and I do this tree view, all I'm
going to see here is a bunch of
page.tsxes most of the time. Uh sorry,
somewhere up here.
How do I hide certain folder? Yeah,
you'll just see a bunch of page.tsxes.
And if I have seven files here, it's
really hard to associate this page.x
with the podcast file. Like that's a lot
of context the LM has to do to link
these two things together. So even
merely dumping this stuff into the
prompt isn't going to naturally get me
to work because the model depends on
connecting those dots together. And
>> this depends this depends on your
finally honed over three plus years
instinct on how do models assign meaning
and how do transformers apply kind of
like oh this is related to this thing
because all the model sees is a string
of tokens.
>> Exactly. So like I'm just like it's
guaranteed that the more files in a
certain directory the worse it's going
to be. So it may not even be that
page.cssx is bad. It's just that I need
to have no directories in there that
start with a p and all my other
directories should start with after a p.
So page.tsx comes up first. Like that's
like the subtle thing that I could do
there and make that not be a problem.
But what I'm saying is if you're a
builder building for builders, think
about this stuff when you build
frameworks. If you're a framework user,
think about this stuff when cloud code
isn't doing it right. Be like, "Oh, this
is probably what's happening. This
codebase has gone long. Let me think
about how I can go solve these
problems."
>> Um, really good question from Pete. I
know he just asked one. Um, but I would
say consider optimizing your uh MCP
tools. If you use a tool all the time,
we use the linear MCP all the time. And
I did say I would share our workflow, so
I'm going to pull that up. Um, we have
to-do, spec needed, research needed,
research in progress, research and
review, ready for plan, plan in
progress, plan and review, ready for dev
indev, code review, ready for deploy. So
we have review steps at every kind of
stage. Um, but also if you look at the
response from the linear MCP server, it
ends up being very noisy. It's a ton of
JSON. And what we've actually built is
um I'm going to try to find this real
quick. Um human layer shared I think
it's tickets. We built a tool that pulls
context optimized linear tickets into
markdown and it has the description and
all the comments in one call. It doesn't
have to make multiple tool calls. We're
working on a thing to actually drop in
the images as well. Um, but this is so
if you're using tools all the time and
you want to use them context
efficiently, consider just making a
script that does it exactly how you want
it.
>> Yeah. And it doesn't even have to do
that. Like you could do compression, you
could do anything you want in that step
to actually put that in there because
maybe there's a common chain. We have a
Discord thread in our Discord that has
like hundreds of messages. I think like
500 messages. Longest Discord thread
I've ever been on in my life. It lasted
four months.
Um, but like likely we don't need things
from like month one anymore in that
Discord thread. It's almost guaranteed
to be irrelevant. So like putting
something on there to like compress that
away would be really really useful.
>> Yeah, love it.
>> The whole like 12 factor agents thing,
right? It's like pick a better data
representation than you know like the
noisy format that you know you're given
natively.
Um I think and then we'll take I guess
two more questions because I really like
uh the question that Pete asked which is
like MCP tools. Um Pete you are 100%
correct. If you use MCPs willy-nilly
that is the same as uh shooting yourself
in the foot as many times as you have
to. Um
>> yeah has been telling people don't put
JSON in the context window for like a
year now.
>> Yeah. The whole point is that MTP is
basically just adding more tools into
your tool context window and you're just
occupying more space. And if you don't
need all those tools, you're just it's
unnecessary.
I I think I'm surprised that as of right
now there's no
not enough people are putting effort
into how to reduce the number of tools
that go into any one system.
But it makes sense. It's a lot of work
and there's no standardized way to go do
it. There's a lot of subjectivity in
there. So the easiest thing to do is to
just dump tools into the context window
and then leave the problem to the user.
So if you are
>> like some people talk I can't remember
what which tool which coding agent it
was but I feel like I remember hearing
something about like having essentially
like a little mini rag system for tools
where like you give the agent like a
tool of like a tool for searching its
tools and then it doesn't do it all the
time. I think John was just mentioning
that too. I I can't remember where I saw
that, but that feels come intuitively
that feels like maybe slightly better.
Like I don't want to have to kind of
like
>> Yeah,
>> I think we had an episode like episode
four or something that does that that
talks about how to deal with like 10,000
plus tools when you have an MCB server
with that many tools. How do you how do
you actually use that in prod and that's
exactly what we do.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh Jen's last question and I think uh we
will pause after that and then uh take a
break.
uh you answered it I think with what you
just said and that's probably where I
read it uh by you in some blog post I'm
guessing uh about the number of tools
that you have enabled in an MC like
either the number of tools that your
current session has access to whatever
that session might be
do you limit that itself
>> way that you do that um essentially.
>> Yeah, just check out the code. I think
the code is live and you can go check
that out. It's probably super easy to go
check it out in that perspective.
>> Um there's a similar video for anyone
interested on the first video we ever
did was how to classify with like 10,000
plus categories.
>> It's the same exact problem and just
like
>> I was going through all those. I just
haven't had time to finish. So,
>> no. Yeah, we we say random words. Dexter
and I say random words all the time. So,
who knows what rand words are actually
useful.
>> Um, but we're basically we're basically
worse LM and sonnet. So, we'll see how
good I
>> have you had for
>> all you know this could be LM generated.
>> Yeah, that's what I think as far as I
know.
>> Yeah. Um, one last thing because there's
a lot of questions on like cloud code
versus Gemini, Amazon's Curo. I mean,
the the goal of this episode is to give
you concepts and principles that are
standard to how LLMs work. Um, obviously
every LM behaves a little bit
differently and they have different
vibes. So like prompts that work really
well for Opus might not really work
really well for 03. And actually like
even the prompts we write for Opus, we
don't use them for Sonnet because Sonnet
like doesn't have the right like like
level of attention to use them well. And
so the idea is like the coding agent is
as good as like how well you understand
it, how good your vibe is, and how much
time you split into crafting your
prompts to encompass these principles.
But at the end of the day, the biggest
takeaway is manage your context window
because the the smaller you can keep
your context windows, the better
performance you will get. And so that's
using sub aents. That's using frequent
intentional compaction. And that's don't
forget to steer. And don't forget to
read everything the model outputs
because the research is super high
leverage. And if the research is wrong,
nothing else is going to work.
>> Yeah, that's a great point to close on.
Um, I'm going to say two last things
really fast that are really short. one,
if you guys enjoyed this stuff, uh, give
us a like on YouTube. Really appreciate
that. That helps. Uh, it helps
>> bring a friend.
>> I told people bring a friend.
>> Um, and then lastly, like if any of you
want to try the thing that Dex is
building, like reach out, message him.
He'll probably give you access. Um,
especially if you're on here, just
mention it. Um, it took me a while to
convince him to give me access, but he
did eventually, and it was nice. Uh,
>> five complained a lot, which I knew he
was going to do.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm a complainer. Um, I will
try most products because I think it's
interesting. I push my limits while I do
that. Um, and then to quite a few of
you, I just want to say like really
really quickly like super super thanks
um to
all of you like we
uh recently just hit like 5,000 stars on
what we're doing uh with BMW and like it
was super meaningful. Uh means a lot to
all of us that for everyone that
support. So like thank you for that. Um,
it's been a wild ride and it's really
cool to be doing this content with Dex
and having you all actually hop in and
listen and waste an hour and a half of
your time. So, it means a lot to us.
We'll hopefully see you guys next week.
>> Well said. Thanks everybody. And I I
will include a link for the uh weight
list to sign up. We're kind of dripping
out signups just so we can make sure we
get all the stability issues out, but
we'll put in the email that we send out
tomorrow.
>> I'll ping you Dex right after this.
>> Yeah, I got you, baby.
>> Good luck everyone. Have fun.
>> Thanks.